the big kahuna in charge of the tour
indeed mike kotakowski also makes great
fashion choices with his jackets
i'm just saying
my welcome to the show
you must be excited to have a season
wrap up
with all the issues with the pandemic
could have been a disaster somewhere
there were some challenges certainly but
the tour did finish successfully
absolutely well we look like twins today
obviously fashionably but yes indeed uh
today is a happy day because we finished
very difficult season
that
when we started we didn't know what
would happen
because
every day it was something new
somebody got sick somebody could not
come
restrictions tests musk
you know
the way of the world
everything
and uh and travel
travel was difficult for everyone
especially to cross the atlantic
so we were able to complete and actually
i take this opportunity to thank
not only players for their courage to
play but for the entire crew i you know
without crew
i won't be able to pull everything up
then
so that i appreciate
tony rich
teresa pripanova
our sponsors and organizers and every
single lack and
last but not least you guys
exceptionally well
done
here in
in in the studio and maurice when you
travel to zagreb
it was
also a big deal well it's fun for us
certainly you guys make it such a
pleasure to have this tour and be a part
of it uh
we now have this conclusion the tour but
we got plans for next year talk about
the new plans well
uh as you remember we already announced
in zagreb
that
five
uh legs of the next year we have full
schedule
uh as gary mentioned today we have
very strong group of sponsors
for next year and actually following
years as well
and
we still contemplating
possibility for the final
after
five lakhs
but we will see whether it would work or
not because next year it's very
difficult
because uh again because of the pandemic
the entire calendar for official
tournaments
uh kind of jumped and after world
championship match that will take place
this year at the end of the year uh
right from february until
mid-april there will be
three tournaments grand prix tournaments
qualifiers for the candidate story then
candidates tournaments then world chess
olympiad
so we needed to
communicate and collaborate with fida in
order to uh
make
balanced well-balanced calendar so
players will not be overwhelmed with all
these tournaments and the same time we
will be able
to host them so therefore next year it's
still
in question in terms of uh
whether we will be able to host finals
or not
and not
you know very difficult to say what
would happen with pandemic because we
still
i have travel bans
to many countries and from many
countries
and we will see how it goes
i'm very positive that whatever we
announce
it will take place right certainly with
all the delta variant and all the issues
that are going on no one can predict
what the world will do uh
you did mention that
next year there may be a finals we
should have the fans know that that
finals means in addition to the five
events post sing field cup then the top
players will come out of that and play a
final as opposed to just accumulating
points alone you did say that you have
plans for the following year 2023
am i hearing potential announcement do
we get any secret inside info i'm not
going to make announcements today but we
definitely have
some extra legs to offer and uh
we will see again how calendar will uh
will look like in 2023
but all these legs that we have plus we
will return back saint louis rapid and
bleeds because in 2022 because we have
new venue in warsaw poland
due to difficulties to accommodate
this on the calendar
we made executive decisions to pull off
rapid and gleasons and clues
although
sponsors organizers and we're all ready
to be here
having said this we definitely will
include back rapid and bleeds in saint
louis in 2023
uh and other events that we already
announced for 2022.
possible one more
it sounds like chess is booming my last
question for you chess is booming not
only is fide doing a lot of things the
grand chester is doing a lot the online
world is also exploded with a magnus
carlson
tour that he's created
and uh other places that have created
their own pog champs and the like yeah
how how what is the challenge like to be
able to fit anything in when the the
chess is just simply more popular than
ever well
we we just need to find the balance
between online events and uh over the
board events i'm sure right now
most of the players are eager to play
over to play over the board just look
what
uh european championship just started in
uh in iceland
and they playing over the board so
uh before it was world cup also you know
i have to give credit to
organizers in in russia because uh they
also dealt with very difficult tasks to
do but
uh to their created they did very well
although
uh there were some hiccups but again
it's not because of organizers because
of pandemic all right well thank you so
much for all the work that you do i know
how many challenges there were
especially at the end only having half
your field of tour participants as well
definitely working it out and making it
happen you do great work thanks so much
thank you thank you too guys thank you
michael very very much and as we heard
there